LUCKILY, NONE OF THE PEOPLE
RESCUED NEEDED MEDICAL
ATTENTION.
WOW!
>>> RIPPED, SHREDDED AND BURNED.
BOMBSHELL REVELATIONS FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST" TAKING US
INSIDE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S "RELENTLESS
DOCUMENT DESTRUCTION HABITS."
JOSH DOSSEE IS WITH US NOW.
THANKS FOR HAVING DINNER WITH US
EARLIER TONIGHT.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES TOLD YOU
THAT TRUMP'S DOCUMENT
DESTRUCTION WAS UNPRECEDENTED.
HOW SO?
>> FOR FOUR YEARS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP RIPPED DOCUMENTS MUNDANE,
LETTERS, MEMOS, FORMAL
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS, PERSONAL
LETTERS, AND IT LED TO A CADRE
OF FOLKS COMING IN AND PUTTING
THESE DOCUMENTS TOGETHER.
WHEN DOCUMENTS CAME INTO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES, THEY FOUND
MANY WERE PUT TOGETHER WITH
TAPE.
SOME WERE NOT PUT TOGETHER AT
ALL, THEY WERE STILL DESTROYED.
BUT HUNDREDS OF DOCUMENTS WERE
PUT TOGETHER BY TAPE.
YOU HAD MANY THINGS THAT HAD
BEEN CLEARLY RIPPED, RIGHT THERE
DOWN THE MIDDLE, SOMETIMES IN
TWO OR THREE PIECES, BUT USUALLY
IN ONE PIECE THAT WENT TO THE
ARCHIVES.
>> SO TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THIS, BECAUSE PRESUABLY
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU DON'T
HAVE, BUT ANY DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE SHRED THAT THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY WANTED
AND IT WASN'T IN THE PILE OR IT
WAS JUST TOO HARD TO PIECE
TOGETHER BECAUSE OF HOW IT WAS
SHREDDED?
>> WELL, SOME OF THE JANUARY 6th
DOCUMENTS THAT WENT TO THE
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN CLEARLY
RIPPED AND SCOTCH TAPED BACK
TOGETHER.
IN OTHER CASES, PARTICULAR
DOCUMENTS, SOME RELATED TO THE
CAMPAIGN TO PRESSURE MIKE PENCE
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION WERE
NOT TURNED OVER, AT LEAST BY
SOME OF OUR SOURCES, BECAUSE
THEY HAD BEEN RIPPED AND
SHREDDED AND IN SOME CASES
BURNED.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE WENT OVER
IS THERE WERE LOTS OF BURN BAGS
IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT ARE
USUALLY USED FOR CLASSIFIED OR
SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS.
IN THIS CASE, ONE OF THE TRUMP
ADVISERS USED THE BURN BAGS FOR
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE NOT
CLASSIFIED OR SENSITIVE.
BUT SOME OF THEM WERE.
IN SOME WAYS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SEE,
BECAUSE A LOT OF PLACES THEY
WERE BURNED OR SHREDDED OR DID
THINGS THAT DID NOT ADHERE TO
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ABOUT.
>> DID YOU GET ANY SENSE FROM
TALKING TO SOURCES ABOUT WHETHER
THIS WAS DONE INTENTIONALLY, FOR
NEFARIOUS PURPOSES TO HIDE
SOMETHING?
WAS IT JUST A MATTER OF HABIT?
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD A
LONG HISTORY OF DOING THIS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE?
>> THAT'S A COMPLICATED QUESTION
TO ANSWER.
A LOT OF SOURCES SAID HE RIPPED
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE BOTH MUNDANE
AND LESS THAN MUNDANE.
BUT THERE DIDN'T SEEM TO BE ANY
PRACTICE OR PATTERN OF WHAT HE
RIPPED IN HALF.
A COUPLE OF SOURCES SAY HE
RIPPED DOCUMENTS THAT HE PUT IN
HIS SHIRT DOCUMENT OR NEVER
RETURNED, WHICH MADE THEM THINK
THEY COULD BE SOMETHING
SENSITIVE.
BUT THE TOTALITY OF OUR SOURCING
INDICATED THERE WAS NO, YOU
KNOW, SPECIFIC REASON THAT HE
WOULD RIP ANY SORT OF DOCUMENT.
BUT HE WOULD RIP ALL SORTS OF
DOCUMENTS AND PUT THEM IN THE
WASTE BIN OF THE OVAL OFFICE,
ALL SORTS OF THINGS FOR PEOPLE
TO ASSEMBLE BACK TOGETHER.
>> TWO FORMER WHITE HOUSE
RECORDS MANAGEMENT DEMONSTRATED
TO CNN IN 2018 SOMEWHAT IT'S
LIKE TO PIECE THESE DOCUMENTS
BACK TOGETHER.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT WAS --
>> TINY PIECES.
MEDIUM SIZED.
>> OKAY.
>> AND THEN WHAT WOULD YOU BOTH
SET ABOUT DOING, DEMONSTRATE FOR
US.
>> LIKE A PUZZLE.
LAY IT OUT ON THE TABLE.
>> AND WE LITERALLY HAD TO SPEND
HOURS PER DAY PIECING TOGETHER A
PUZZLE.
>> WOW!
WAS THERE ANY ATTEMPT WHATSOEVER
IN THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE TO
ADHERE TO THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, AS YOU DETAIL MD
STAFFERS WOULD SCRAMBLE WHEN HE
WOULD RIP SOMETHING UP AND TRY
TO PIECE IT TOGETHER.
>> WELL, AFTER THAT STORY, AND
EVEN BEFORE THAT STORY,VARIOUSE
FROM SELF-LAWYERS THAT THIS
NEEDED TO STOP AND THOSE
CONCERNS DO NOT -- OR DID NOT GO
ANYWHERE.
THE WHITE HOUSE DECIDED BECAUSE
HE WAS NOT GOING TO STOP, ALL
THEY COULD DO ON THE BACK END IS
PUT THEM BACK TOGETHER.
SO YOU HAD THIS REALLY EXTENSIVE
EFFORT THAT INCLUDED THE STAFF
SECRETARY'S OFFICE.
THE OFFICE OF RECORDS
MANAGEMENT, VARIOUS AIDES WHO,
INSTEAD OF CONVINCING HIM HEY,
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU NEED TO STOP
RIPPING THESE DOCUMENTS UP, JUST
GO THROUGH AND PICK UP -- LOOK
AT PILES AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND TRY TO PUT THEM TOGETHER.
AFTER THAT STORY, THERE WAS LOTS
OF CONSTERNATION IN THE WHITE
HOUSE OF, WE NEED TO CHANGE
THIS, THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY A